bonjour et bien des bonal
la leçon aujourd'hui avec notre
consultant je voulais vraiment beaucoup
jean luc bonjour stéphane grand maître
international
oui depuis 2000 en dépit des médias et
notamment auteur de je crois trois
grandes roues tant par les trois grandes
parties contre des champions du monde
puisque tu as joué je crois trois
champions du jean n'est joué 4 4 4 dans
le monde donc j'ai joué boris j'ai joué
talent en 90 oui ça date un talon 58
champions 58 60 ans 60 67 avant ce terme
soit 57,1 pas bon et donc j'ai joué au
total j'ai fait match nul
j'ai joué ensuite votre spassky l'année
d'après et j'ai fait match nul
après c'est un petit peu plus du en 93
j'ai joué contre eux garry kasparov et
là je dois avouer que j'ai perdu
justement c'était oui c'était quand même
une partie
un grand moment et puis la dernière
partie donc j'ai joué contre karpov
matches aller retour au grand prix de
bordeaux et l'aj donc bon je pense que
j'ai fait un demi sur deux et c'était un
résultat tout à fait honorable puisque
je suis tombé dans une partie et puis
dans la deuxième on va dire qu'il va le
petit cadeau de la nulle mais la
position était égal à poser sur la fin
était légale alors aujourd'hui notre
autre quadruple médaillé championnats du
monde on peut dire très humble donc du
coup va nous parler tu vas nous par les
ennuis de la défense française donc je
vais vous parler de la défense française
et je vais finalement donc donné aux
internautes et aux téléspectateurs une
possibilité pour reprendre l'avantagé
donc pour essayer d'obtenir avoir une
bonne position avec les blancs donc on
va s'intéresser à la position avec trois
cavaliers c3 alors donc voyons voyons
cet échiquier
donc on va commencer la partie donc eu 4
ou 6 1 tandis que peut-être juste le
temps à la régie de nous montrer notre
échiquier convoi en petit pour l'instant
voilà on est passé de mode et chic et
alors qu'on va commencer la partie donc
que 4,6 alors ça ça caractérise la
défense française la deuxième coup au
cices c'est le coup car est ainsi de la
défense française donc on constate que
les noirs n'occupe pas directement le
centre par le coût de 7,5 mais juste un
petit coup de pions donc le coût
principal
évidemment c'est de pousser les pions de
deux cases là ils ont comme ils l'ont
poussée d'une seule case donc c'est pas
oui oui tout à fait alors ça caractérise
alors le deuxième coup le plus le plus
le plus courant c'est après d'occuper
les centres tout simplement des clubs
lens assez classique voilà qu'on
conseille de toute façon oui tout à fait
impossible mais ça c'est des coups
secondaire oui donc il faut jouer dans
cette position il faut jouer t4 et là on
joue donc des sacs
voilà c'est l'idée du coup aussi c'est
de préparer cette poussée centrale ici
alors essentiellement ce qu'on peut
noter jean luc le problème
demande de cette approche par les noirs
un avantage c'est que c'est très solide
au centre voilà mais l'inconvénient
c'est que ça en fait on se fout ça enfin
de ce fou donc est bon sur la vente
principal enfin sur la vente d'avant ce
que nous allons pas abordé aujourd'hui
sur le cou aux 4 5 ha de sau coup là
donc la caractéristique de la française
donc sur leurs ancêtres ce pion ce
serait de ce serait de jouer donc le
coup
c'est cette c5 d'avancer ses pions pour
casser finalement le centre d'accord
alors on va juste montrer donc sur sur
cette langue d'avant ce que tous les
montres et la possibilité ou c'est de
casser les cintres alors c'est parce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est le coup le
peut-être un peu plus standard le coup
cavaliers c3 qui a qui est beaucoup plus
classique puisque y développe une pièce
et en même temps il défend
voilà donc un coût plus classique plus
agressif qui permet de jouer une vraie
position ouverte et là en fait que tu va
nous montrer jean-luc 6,7 cette position
là qu est la clé de la leçon
d'aujourd'hui
voilà donc je vais vous montrer
plusieurs solutions avec les blancs pour
pour jouer cette ouverture en fonction
des réponses noir d'accord donc trois
grands embranchements voilà donc on va
commencer
on va peut-être montré ses trois ans
franchement quel prix on va les analyser
en paroles donc d'abord possibilité de
jouer le cavalier ici avec six
attaquants le pion central développant
une pièce dont cavaliers fisc est le
coup le plus classique pour agences
françaises deuxième coup classique aussi
qui a ainsi visité peut-être moins
maintenant c'est le coup sous des quatre
fous des quatre qui est également très
jouée qui à coup classique mais qui a
cours comment dire un peu plus tactique
un peu plus agressif et qui en général
joué par des joueurs un peu plus
expérimentés alors l'idée c'est qu'on
attaque aussi le pion ici on l'attaqué
directement à l'heure avec le cavalier
qui attaque et le pion mais ici on
l'attaquent indirectement puisque ce
câble ils ne publient bouger puisque
derrière le fou ya le roi danse et me
lecavalier qui est cloué donc on parle
de clouage dans cette position cavalier
ici et cloud est ce qu'on appelle coup
il peut pas bouger interdit pour ce
cavalier de bouger donc on peut le
mettre de toutes les couleurs mais il ne
peut pas bouger peut pas bouger en
plumes et ailes brûlures mais il bougera
pas bayrou donc le dernier coup
des ondées prendre quatre derniers coups
derrière embranchements possibles qui on
prend le cas tout simplement voilà on
élimine tous les problèmes voilà donc
d'attaquer le pion on le prend mais on
n'abandonne nouveau centre voilà c'est
une solution simplificatrice
j'expliquerai les idées de ce coup tout
à l'heure donc je pense que le plus
important maintenant c'est de commencer
par couper 4 on a commencé par cb 4
voilà notre certaines variantes donc fou
bekkat donc comme le pion leucate est
attaqué on le pousse voilà donc ici on
touche le pion il ya d'autres coups
possibles il ya d'autres coups possibles
par exemple ce coup-là d'américains oui
au moins on peut s'amuser à jouer des
coups alors attaqué lequel j'essaie
d'être mais c'est un peu tactique mais
ça demande quand même plus de
concentration plus de connaissances
alors on jouera donc le coup plutôt
voilà est donc là le coût principal des
noirs dans cette défense française le
coup ces sept saissac
quant à un coût très important puisque
les noirs veulent casser ce centre est
extrêmement classique 1 voilà dans la
française c'est très décoller noël dès
que les blancs et avancer ici on va
toujours toujours créer une rupture ici
au centre
l'idée c'est d'attaquer la chaîne de
cette minichaîne de pions voilà on
attaque la base toujours en sait pour
plus facile d'attaquer la base puisque
la tête s'y est bien défendu mais la
base ne l'est pas et on va essayer de
casser cette structure parce que si ce
pion disparaît et bien c'est la tête qui
va devenir faible exactement donc coup
classique et là tout nous propose
janvier qu'une variante tout à fait
intéressante
alors je vous propose une vente
secondaire mais qui est tout à fait
intéressante qui est facile à jouer
l'avant principal dans cette position
c'est le coût à 3 donc attaquer il faut
en p4 ainsi parce que tu conseilles non
c'est parce que je pensais mais je veux
juste montrer va montrer donc là le fugu
d'attaqué donc la réponse classique
j'essaie de prendre le cavalier prendre
cavaliers on reprend du pied aux aînés
tenant la bafin la base qui était
attaquée est défendue par un pion mais
le problème c'est qu'on a quand même des
pions voilà il faut savoir jouer des
pions doublé ça demande un petit peu
plus d'expérience donc moi je vais vous
conseiller le coût 5 fu des deux dans
cette position donc je vous
conseillerais le plan de juifs ou des
dessous des 2 et ça c'est ça c'est un
joli coup que je connaissais pas et que
tous nous apprend aujourd hui en uc
c'est un très joli coup parce qu'on va
voir l'idée derrière lol quel est ce
qu'il ya une menace pour les blancs tout
de suite
alors pour l'instant
il n'y a pas vraiment de menaces il ya
comme un coût auquel il faut se méfier
c'est le coup donc dans cette position
c'est le coup cavaliers les 5
le cavalier qui vient sur la case v5
faut se méfier de ce coup là pour les
blancs voilà pour les noirs doivent se
méfier mais c'est un groupe table encore
une fois que lecavalier serait que ce
dessin qu'il pourrait éventuellement
aller sur la case des six faire échec
des rockets droite vers ce nom en
empêcher de rock et pour ce jour
protégés par un pion dans le cas inverse
exactement alors bon dans cette position
évidemment stéphane tu vas peut-être
proposer donc le coup candidats pour les
noirs le premier conte qui tient à
l'esprit après fait des deux est bien
moins le coût qui me vient à l'esprit de
simplement s'il me dire voilà ceux qui
ont des 4 eh bien il n'est pas on va
juste enlever les flèches ce pion des
quatre ici les plus protégés par la date
donc il est en prise voilà je me dis
tout simplement le coup naturel semble
être et bien un pion pions 34 oui et
puis on prend des quatre donc il n'est
pas un très très beau ou puisque le
cavalier c3 vient sur la case b5 comme
je les dis alors là tu constates que le
fou d2 et le fourbe et 400 vis-à-vis oui
donc il va peut-être falloir échanger
tofu et si tu prends le fondé de jeu
reprend de la dame
donc maintenant vu empêcher les chèques
on peut plus empêcher les chèques
si tu viens l'art par exemple pour
attaquer le pion aux 5
je ne suis même pas obligé de faire un
chèque tout de suite je peux d'abord
défendre mon pions avoir une chaîne de
pions c'est très important d'avoir une
chaîne de pions donc je soutiens pion
central par le pion f4 mon développement
sera naturel puisque ce cavalier va
pouvoir revenir sur la case f3 je
récupérerai assez facilement le pion
central ou inception en plus c'est
indéfendable et à n'importe quel moment
ce cavalier va pouvoir rebondir sur les
cases des six pour faire échec
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de risque sur
qui on prend des quatre derniers coups à
regarder peut-être juste on voudrait
voir jean-luc alors si on prend des
claques allée b 5e je voudrais quand
même qu'on a eu
la démonstration est si alors si les
noirs par exemple reculer leurs fous par
exemple en deux sets
alors si le voit ensuite plus tôt
peut-être pour pas gêner la sortie de
leurs cavaliers être ensuite ici comme
ça donc dans cette position on peut
envisager plusieurs bons coups et peut
tout simplement reprendre
on peut reprendre on peut jouer d'abord
f4 le pion va être le plan de façon le
plan des cats et il est perdu on protège
et ensuite on sur le cavalier voilà
exactement d'accord et alors si si on
voit cette variante pions prendre en
cavalier ces six f4
alors si les noirs attaque la chaîne de
pions ici menaçant de sicile et blanc
font échec
on va ensuite miné 7,7 défense du
cavalier enfin je pense que dans cette
position il ya tout simplement il n'y a
qu'à jouer cavalier f3 défendre ses
pions et tout simplement et avec une
position tout à fait correct tout à fait
jouable et on reprendra peut-être du
cavalier ici en fait voilà on fera pas
l'échec parce que ça risque d'être un
peu dangereuse non oui on n'est pas
pressé un transfert choisi et mon
dernière chose à préciser c'est donc
c'est sûr food et 2 on revient donc un
petit peu en arrière
une chose importante sur food et deux si
on joue dans cette position cavaliers c6
directement ça sera notre cool très
intéressant donc là évidemment si tu es
bien compris le coup clé de cette
position où ils clament à libé c'est un
cavalier bessac très important on n'a
pas peur de perdre ce pion ce pion des
cats ya toujours le vis-à-vis et ben
c'est toujours la vente qu'on a vu voilà
à peu près la même bande qu'on a vu le
vis-à-vis entre les fous donc on peut
pas se [ __ ] en voile a donné ensuite
qu'à valider six échecs exactement dont
parle si on échange des fous dans cette
position donc si je vous prends en fout
on reprend la dame est sûre cavaliers
prend des cats par exemple là on peut
on peut prendre en déca tout simplement
et on va récupérer le pion après ce qui
est bien lancée mais on joue avec kat
d'abord sans doute on peut jouer avec
quatre cavaliers f3 de toute façon ce
qui est bien dans cette position c'est
que le fou c'est 8 n'est pas très bien
développé voilà ce full un problème il a
du mal à sortir ils enfermaient donc
avec les blancs on a gardé des bonnes
pièces on se garde même la possibilité
de faire grand roque qui peut être assez
agressif pour attaquer droite vers snow
le roi noir qui ferait petit rock donc
sur une position facile à jouer une fois
c'est officiel de la corde très bien
donc sous les 4 je pense que mon coude
est le le couple est conseillé par jean
luc chabanon dans cet orient tu sais
pourquoi pas essayer
c'est une belle nouvelle technique oui
je pense que femmes en moi je ne joue
pas eu 4 et je dois avouer que si je
devais jouer cette position j'aurais
probablement recours à des sous
variantes comme fou des deux d'ailleurs
j'ai même vu que des species de quatre
jours le courroux des deux pour éviter
les grandes lignes théorique de ce qu'on
appelle la vente vie 9 heures après le
coup à trois d'accord donc là on a vu ce
qu ont conseillé surtout b4 voilà donc
maintenant on va regarder de desproges
cap on doit regarder des princes donc
alors on va pas enlever un petit peu en
arriver là tout à fait ici non ça donne
juste ici donc
qu'avec des c3 et des propos l'un des
princes lors d'épreuves 4 le coût des
blancs cavaliers pro 4 classique entre
un pion et le coût des noirs logique ces
cavaliers de céder cette danse cavaliers
alors attention on pourquoi qu'à valider
ce n'était pas cavalier m6 alors terré
ci semble logique puisqu'on on développe
une pièce tout en attaquant ici ce
cavalier mais tout simplement prendre et
c'est sa voix sur cavaliers apsys donc
j'avais déjà analyser la position ici
donc son cavalier et six cavaliers pros
f6 dame prend m6 et cavaliers f3 qui
menacent fou c'est un g5 et la dame
perdrait beaucoup de temps d'accord et
si on prend pas de la dame
ça veut dire qu'on prend du pion donc on
va dire qu'on prend du plomb m6 se doit
avouer quand même qu'avec un pion nous
plaît on n'a pas une position
extraordinaire pour une ouverture à moi
tout à fait dans cette position donc là
on va donc voir ce qui se passe après le
coup cavaliers 17
donc là plusieurs possibilités encore
une fois posés chaque île enfin
plusieurs embranchements le coût
principal cavaliers f3 locaux facile à
retenir sinon sur food et 3 c'est une
idée intéressante bon à jouer à
expérimenter un petit peu plus tard
après cavalière trois cavaliers apsys on
peut jouer dame eux deux alors là j'ai
déjà mis les flèches c'est tout près
voilà dames 2 tout simplement pour
mettre le fou c'est un sur la case des
deux et ensuite faire le dos rond et
ensuite faire le grand roque
donc ça c'est pour les joueurs d'attac
pur et dur quoi oui voilà une solution
pour les genres d'attac pleurer mais ça
c'est bien parce qu'en général jour de
cadres sont des joueurs d'attaqué il
n'aime pas trop la française qui plutôt
une position de manoeuvre en général et
en plus une position des changes puisque
là dans cette position après cavaliers
f6 les noirs venus échanger lecavalier
va les changer encore ce cavalier au
centre il cavaliere 4 contre ce cavalier
là et plus tard poussé ce plan sur ces
cinq pour éliminer définitivement donc
le centre pour qu'il n'y ait plus du
tout deux pièces au centre donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai conseillé donc cette
vente avec foot est roi où cavaliers f3
très classique d'accord cavaliers f6
donc là en échange x change il faut pas
chercher à faire pas faire cher changé à
faire autre chose exactement
là encore plusieurs embranchements donc
c'est vrai que des points 4 c'est un
petit peu c'est c'est assez multiplient
un choix multiple dans cette position
donc par exemple on peut jouer fouet
trois ça c'est la dernière tendance donc
je vais pas trop développé ce coup
laurent frayssinet la jouer au
championnat de france
il a gagné une partie est très très être
très joli avec ce coup sinon on peut
aussi jouer food et 3 ultra classique
wii donc là on va reste naturel pour le
fou là gaz naturel saissac donc la
fameuse façon classique encore le coup
thématiques pour échanger le centre pour
les descentes
donc à part dans ce cas là exactement
donc après c'est ça que la pression est
forte quand même oui on peut échanger
faut penser ça que bon on a une position
classique et le coup que j'ai que je
propose donc le coup ces trois donc le
coup c3 qui est un petit coup un petit
peu un petit peu plus subtil c'est à
dire qu'après le coup c'est un classique
toujours pour échanger le centre oui là
on place un cavalier en avant postes sur
la case e5 d'accord en place un cavalier
sur un 15 2 5 et est ce que tu comprends
l'idée de se connaître
en général quand on place un cavalier
ici il faut noter que lecavalier
ici contrôler les cases blanches
peut-être ici donc on peut être en
menacent de faire un petit échec qui
cale à embêtant puisque il va il va un
peu difficile à défendre très bien mon
cher stéphane c'est vrai que dans cette
position si les noirs après cavaliers 5
jouer le couffo eu 7
le fou viendrai soit 15 des chats des
sacs et frais échec au roi
donc là on verrait qu'il ya un échec est
bon on va pas dire hostile roi cavaliers
17 c'est pas très beau site cavalli
revient sur 17
ces passifs on est mal développées et si
vous le foot revient sur des simples le
coût normal dans ces cas là on ne peut
prendre ce que l'on appelle la paire de
fou voilà on à la paire de fonds prend
des 7 et la honda espère de wanda de fou
dans une position ouverte c'est un
avantage c'est un avantage donc le court
principal s'est assise pour éviter
foulée cinq échecs après à 6 on joue
fouet trois ont continué à se développer
si par exemple l'adversaire échanges
au centre on peut tout simplement
reprendre de la dame et avoir plus de
pièces développées d'accord donc plus de
pièces développées dans une position
ouverte c'est quand même un avantage
d'accord on reprendrait pas des pions
parce qu'on se créerait un pion isolé
non on promet exactement a pu isoler
donc très important si on reprend
d'union le pion isolé c'est pas très
beau
c'est une petite faiblesse dans sa
position c'est pas nécessaire il ya des
fossés bon mais là c'est vraiment pas le
cas donc après tab c7 bondam acat échec
par exemple toujours avec la fameuse
idée fou 17
on prend la paire de fonds prend la
paire de fou et sur des scènes donc il
le faut et 3 et le fond f1 et sur des
scènes qui a une astuce et sur des sacs
donc très très important aussi sur des
sacs et une astuce qui perdent tout de
suite c'est qu'on prend donc avec le
fouet f1 on prend le pion donc le cube
et s'arrête donc je vais jouer le coup
échec échec et le pion à six ne peut pas
reprendre le fou puisque danseuse dans
cette poésie sommet d'ascalon c'est une
grave erreur oui puisqu'on perd la tour
et là tant qu'on a la position déjà
gagné en tout et le bénin puisque on a
une qualité ce qui bon c'est gagnant
pour les grands joueurs évidemment à peu
après ça dépend un caniveau jouit en
tout cas c'est un avantage net
oui c'est un avantage net donc le coût
principal c'est qu'à valider cette c'est
un retrait c'est le retrait le plus le
plus joué et on peut après un coup comme
petit rock par exemple plus on prend
pour éliminer le centre donc cavalier
prend 17 parce que maintenant le
cavalier emprise lui il faut les changer
le camp que dans cette position le la
dame noire après il apprend des cats
menacerait de prendre le cam iron sac
donc après cavaliers prend 17 oui faut
prendre date pour des 4 on a un petit
avantage de développement donc une
position assez confortable
d'accord donc maintenant je pense que
on avait on a vu on a à peu près tout vu
sur le coût des projets 400d prend 2,4
donc je reviens sur la position
classique sur la position classique donc
on vient de voir des princes 4 on va en
fait on vient de voir ce qu'on voit là
donc on va en fait maintenant revenir
sur à dans ce plan moi je vais y arriver
cabaye et ses trois-quarts et ses 3 et
canal et m6 et wing cavalière 6
annoncera ce moulin à vent non c'est pas
ça touche je ne serai plus à jour à la
projo mettront aux cavaliers pts 6 voilà
s'est appuyé sur la touche
yoann est d'accord donc cavalier apsys
donc encore une fois l'attention le
cavaliere à m6 qui attaquent le pion le
pion central
oui donc il faut pousser tout simplement
hélas le cavalier qui doit revenir sur
une case sur sa case naturel la case 17
pour permettre donc
le contre au centre à savoir qu'un
cavalier sur leucate ce ne serait pas
très bon puisqu'on pourrait prendre le
cadre et ce pur 4 et un peu tout seul il
n'est pas soutenu donc il va y risque le
risque de tomber tôt ou tard ça va être
difficile à défendre
excellent cible c'est une cible non
c'est pas vraiment possible tout de
suite c'est pas une chose aller c'est
donc validé cette f4 avoir une belle
chaîne de pions très important quand
toujours ce fameux contre 4 quand on
peut le faire dans les français c'est
bon exactement donc f4 ces sacs pour
casser le centre donc la main d'oeuvre
classique de la française toujours pour
contester le centre cavaliers trois
cavaliers c6 donc cavalier de troie qui
défense entre 4 et 6 qui réattaque le
centre donc on voit toutes les pièces
qui qui s'intéressent au centre la lutte
pour le centre est de plus en plus
acharnée
voilà la tension et après qu'amélie c6
foule 3 toujours pour défendre le centre
voilà donc là le coût principal pop en
d4
alors on peut être liberticide attention
des pays notés le piège classique peut
être jean luc si on joue d'amd 6
peut-être que les blancs peuvent jouer
le coup classique cavaliers à 4 donc
alors on va on va juste revenir sur
l'a26 et au dessus d'accord ça déjà été
préparée que d'appeler six cavaliers à
quatre attaques la dame est là la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est que
se passe-t-il si la dame bien sûr la
case à sac
oui en faisant échec voilà fait échec
effet une fourchette quand on va voir
dans la saq attaque le roi et attaque le
cavalier avait fait ce qu'on fait c'est
embêtant on a l'impression qu'il faut
ramener le cavalier sur la case c3 eh
bien non dans cette position on peut
jouer pioncer 3 voilà c'est l'astuce le
pion c3 qui intercepte l'échec de la
dame sur le roi ly et qui permet à la
dame d un donc de défendre le cavalier
classique
voilà donc un coup classique et après
ces trois venaient à connaître dans la
défense française cette astuce louis
bélanger général mais ce piège de
pousser leurs pions pour défendre le
cavalier
et un coût important sur damas cinq
façons faut toujours faire attention
fourchette en cours verra on verra dans
une leçon sur la fourchette
éventuellement donc ces trois et l'a
donc après un coup comme s'éprend des 4
par exemple on chausse la dame
donc on cherche saddam la dame ne peut
toujours pas reprendre le cavalier parce
qu'il est défendu par la dame en d1
ce cavalier toujours défendu par cette
dame donc la dame doit revenir sur la 4c
7 et on reprend au centre avec un petit
avantage des spasmes des positions un
roman prend pas évidemment du pian
puisque on perdrait le pion le tombé 4
il se serait passif en général quand on
quand on reprend ici avec les blancs sur
cette case des cats on préfère toujours
reprendre avec une pièce souvent
d'ailleurs de même un cavalier qui est
très bien placée notamment qui contrôle
les casots 6 6 1 qui peuvent aider à des
puces et peut-être des pions plus tard
oc et kg là sont très très bien placé et
on va essayer de se servir de cette case
des quatre communes cas ce qui vaut pour
les pièces y en a pas peur de se
mouiller en arriérés parce que très
souvent les blancs arrive à l'échangé à
anjouan c4 et surtout là dans sa
position aussi n'oublions pas ce fou ans
et 8 qui et qui enterraient donc il faut
jouer là dessus
et puis il faut développer rapidement
c'est-à-dire sortir ce fou ici ou là par
exemple pour pouvoir faire le petit rock
rapidement et après engager les actions
on a le choix parce qu'on peut soit
engagé des actions de ce côté là avec
une tour ici vous imaginez comme c'est
fort soi même de l'autre côté on peut
parfois on protège dents on protège
d'abord b4 et ensuite on peut vous jouer
c4 et donc on est on est bon des deux
côtés en fait voilà on est très bon donc
on va donc reprendre la variante au
départ donc là après cavani prendrait
quatre le goût classique faisait ça pour
se développer toujours contrôler la case
des quatre la case centrale donc le fou
qui contrôle toujours été centrale dam
des deux pour se développer
alors là il ya une variante qu'on va
dire un peu des pères c'est à dire ouais
ouais jouer cavalier prend foot sang
froid d'un point et d'anne decis pour
tout échange et on accepte le challenge
on veut bien jouer une finale mais quand
même on a un petit plus aux menaces une
fourchette avec lecavalier
on a une bonne chaîne de pions et le
fouet adverse ayant fermé on sait bien
que c'est un petit plus ce qui fait que
dans cette position les joueurs
préfèrent plutôt que tout l'échangé
jouer à 6 d'accord grand roque
on pense à l'action d'un attaquant pas
mal petit rock donc là ça va être une
partie très aigu ça va être chaud
roy b1 donc ça c'est une position
lascive classe élite eric prophylactique
ce genre de coups et là on va voir donc
un plan classique
après quelques échanges oui la dame c7
les noirs dont continuent leur
développement mais là les blancs passe à
l'attack h4h 4 alors c'est quoi le plan
dans ta tête et droit commencent à
ouvrir et à gaza trois pour la tour les
noirs font la même chose
oui ils passent à l'action face au roi
devait donc le plan des 5 face au roi
bien assez chaud voilà c'est très chaud
la tombe bien sûr h3 oui pour défendre
un peu vite pour attaquer donc la tour
qui à la fois à contrôler donc la 3d
tout la troisième rangée comme ça en
défense mais aussi en attaque et qui en
attaque puisque éventuellement elle
pourrait venir sur la case d3 face au
roi ouais donc une tour qui est
multifonction voilà bi fonction on va
dire mais très souvent tric trac est
très classique ce genre de
d'activation de la torah oui tout à fait
dans des quatre attaques lecavalier
lecavalier rebondi sur une case où il
chasse le fou le fou s'échange tour ici
et là un coût très important pour
continuer la tacc donc faut continuer à
attaquer sur une aile il est souvent
important de contrôler le centre donc la
tour 3 c'est un coup de champion du
groupe puisque ces vices manhattan ans
qui a joué ça dans une partie à
stuttgart en 2002 ont tour à trois qui
défend le pion aux trois donc cinq
pointures le sac donc il ya défendu par
la tour et par la dame d'accord donc la
dame des cats défend aussi ce pion le
pire de saintes et et qui permet donc
l'avancée du pion f5 l'avancée du plan
est de 5 pour lancer une attaque
préparée f5 et éventuellement après les
7,6 dans castle rock adverse pour casser
le rock et et magnin droit adverse
on va sans doute aussi pouvoir jouer le
fou ici sur cette case avait des
possibilités peut-être de sacrifices aux
sacrifices exactement mais c'est vrai
que c'est très chaud et que ça a l'air
assez pénible à défendre ses classiques
de la défense française de le dire et
alors là eux et loire ou l'ain je vous
dirais comme il nous dit souvent très
bien c'est c'est la chaîne de pian qui
détermine la tacc le pion est en avance
et ici du côté droit donc on va plutôt
attaquer facilement de ce côté là alors
que les noirs vont pouvoir plutôt
attaquer du côté dames
mais là on a de l'avancé et on a de
l'avancé on à l'avant ça me touche
beaucoup plus avancé et des pièces mieux
développés qui peuvent coulisser
éventuellement est donc ici le plan cfcm
quand est ce qu'on va certainement jouer
soit 60 au t3 soit salarié chez 4 est
envisageable
alors j'ai quatre ans vise à mettre dans
cette position se serait peut-être un
peu maladroit qu'il faut jouer f5 apsys
le plus de 5 et 6 faut pas finasser
parce que c'est un problème c'est que ça
bouge que les colonnes si ça bougerait
les colonnes c'est un conte breurey
puisque c'est vrai que la dame si on
joue et g4 les dames sur des quatre ne
pourraient pas venir sur la cage et 4
pour mater le roi est tout à fait donc
ces espions on va aller au groupe droit
au but avec f 5 m6 vraiment très
intéressant la marche on a fait le tour
oui je crois qu'on a fait le tour de
cette france qu'on a vu de très belles
armes ici contre contre la défense
française notamment 7 7 dernières
grandes variantes donc mais on peut que
vous inviter à prendre ces variantes
dans votre répertoire et surtout
peut-être on le dira souvent on dit
souvent dans ses émissions
c'est de vous inspirer des idées des
idées stratégiques qui est de comprendre
les idées parce que sinon une fois qu'on
a compris des idées on peut soi-même
retrouver les bons dans les ouvertures
le plus important donc c'est de
comprendre les idées c'est de bien
connaître les plans aux échecs et après
c'est vrai qu'on peut tout re découvrir
soi-même sur l'échiquier voit la super
donc c'était une excellente je crois le
son sur la défense française qui a
laissé 3 par le grand maître
international
sonic chabanon une compagnie 4,4
champion du monde à son palmarès
enfin pas en victoire mais en partie
c'est déjà bien il n'y a pas beaucoup de
monde je pense donc aujourd'hui sur
total
ouais je faire talent et kasparov le
dernier kramnik aussi non nantes akram
n'est pas grave non pas encore mais je
le connais mais je fais pas ouvrir
talent et kasparov
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde qui l'a
fait dans mon histoire
espérons que j'ai joué à futur champion
du monde en la personne d' etienne
bacrot un bon repas mais pourquoi pas et
on sait pas à bientôt sur une autre
leçon